of biological pests controlling sweet pepper
under protection,
75 percent of the pesticides were actually reduced.
And Israeli strawberries, even more --
80 percent of the pesticides,
especially those aimed against pest mites in strawberries.
So the impact is very strong.
And there goes the question,
especially if you ask growers, agriculturists:
Why biological control?
Why good bugs?
By the way, the number of answers you get
equals the number of people you ask.
But if we go, for example, to this place, Southeast Israel,
the Arava area above the Great Rift Valley,
where the pearl of Israeli agriculture is located,
especially under greenhouse conditions, or under screenhouse conditions --
if you drive all the way to Eilat, you see this
just in the middle of the desert.
And if you zoom in,
you can definitely watch this:
grandparents with their grandchildren,
distributing the natural enemies, the good bugs,
instead of wearing special clothes
and gas masks and applying chemicals.
So safety, with respect to the application,
is the number one answer that we get from growers,
for "Why biological control?"
Number two, many growers are, in fact, petrified
by the idea of resistance,
that the pests will become resistant to the chemicals,
just like in our case, that bacteria becomes resistant to antibiotics.
It's the same, and it can happen very quickly.
Fortunately, in either biological control or even natural control,
resistance is extremely rare.
It hardly happens.
Because this is evolution, this is the natural ratio,
unlike resistance, which happens in the case of chemicals.
And thirdly, public demand.
The more the public demands the reduction of chemicals,
the more growers become aware of the fact
that they should, wherever they can and wherever possible,
replace the chemical control with biological control.
Even here, there is another grower,
you see, very interested in the bugs, the bad ones and the good ones,
wearing this magnifier already on her head,
just walking safely in her crop.
Finally, I want to get to my vision,
or, in fact, to my dream.
Because, you see, this is the reality.
Have a look at the gap.
If we take the overall turnover
of the biocontrol industry worldwide,
it's 250 million dollars.
And look at the overall pesticide industry
in all the crops throughout the world.
I think it's times 100 or something like that.
Twenty-five billion.
So there is a huge gap to bridge.
So actually, how can we do it?
How can we bridge, or let's say, narrow, this gap over the years?
First of all, we need to find more robust,
good and reliable biological solutions,
more good bugs that we can either mass-produce
or actually conserve in the field.
Secondly, to create even more intensive and strict public demand
for the reduction of chemicals in agricultural fresh produce.
And thirdly, also to increase awareness by the growers
to the potential of this industry.
And this gap really narrows.
Step by step, it does narrow.
So I think my last slide is:
All we are saying -- we can actually sing it --
Give nature a chance.
I'm saying it on behalf of all the biocontrol practitioners
and implementers,
in Israel and abroad,
really give nature a chance.
Thank you.
(Applause)